listen listen everyone nobody can leave
this building but we need supplies food
silicone you go outside and you'll die
by now the global warming has shifted
the climate bringing on a new Ice Age
within the hour the temperature outside
will fall to over 70 million de below
zero Jesus all we can do is try to wait
it out as long as we can and the rest of
the
country
everyone below this line will have to be
evacuated to the South everyone above
this line is already
dead people like us in the middle states
have to ride it out the baly
southwestern States might have a chance
but New York will have tidal waves that
envelop all of the
Northeast what
Frank oh oh God damn it that's some
quality comedy right there